wir haben gerade eine so glaube ich
historische Landesvorstandssitzung der
Berliner CDU erlebt wir haben heute über
die sondierungsergebnisse berichtet die
wir in den letzten Tagen nach dem 12
Februar nach der Wiederholungswahl
hatten
und ich habe ausführlich gemeinsam mit
meinem Generalsekretär Stefans über die
Sondierungsgespräche berichtet sie
wissen dass wir gute Gespräche jeweils
drei sowohl mit der SPD als auch mit den
Grünen hatten und ich möchte mich bei
beiden Parteien ganz herzlich für die
guten Gespräche bedanken wir hatten gute
offene und vertrauensvolle Gespräche mit
den Sozialdemokraten und wir hatten auch
gute offene sehr verlässliche und
vertrauensvolle Gespräche mit den Grünen
und ich möchte mich in diesem
Zusammenhang natürlich gerade auch bei
den Berliner Grünen bedanken
weil es wirklich gute Gespräche waren
wir haben gerungen um die besten Punkte
die besten Lösungen für Berlin wir haben
festgestellt dass es Unterschiede gibt
große Gräben aber wir haben auch mit den
Grünen immer wieder versucht Brücken zu
bauen und das ist uns in vielen Punkten
auch mit den Berliner grün gelungen
hier ist ein neues Verhältnis entstanden
auch ein neues Vertrauen zwischen CDU
und Grünen und dafür bin ich den Grünen
sehr dankbar und nichtsdestotrotz gibt
es natürlich deutlich mehr Schnittmengen
inhaltliche Schnittmengen mit den
Sozialdemokraten
und auch hier haben wir intensiv
gerungen und gesprochen über die Art und
Weise wie wir zukünftig die Stadt
voranbringen wollen über Probleme über
Herausforderungen über eine Politik die
alle in den Blick nimmt und eine
berlin-koalition die auf Vernunft
basiert und demzufolge habe ich heute
aufgrund der vielen gemeinsamen
Schnittmengen mit den Sozialdemokraten
dem Landesvorstand der Berliner CDU
vorgeschlagen
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der Berliner
SPD aufzunehmen
und der Landesvorstand der Berliner CDU
hat dies einstimmig also mit 100%
beschlossen
wir werden jetzt in die
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit den
Sozialdemokraten gehen
wir haben eine ganz klare Prämisse
wir wollen das Berlin Berlin bleibt
aber Berlin an allen Stellen wieder
funktioniert wir wollen nicht dass
Berlin sich tagtäglich neu erfindet
sondern dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Basics in unserer Stadt wieder stimmen
dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Verwaltung funktioniert das Verfahren
gestrafft werden dass es schneller geht
in Bürgerämtern und vielen anderen
Themen wir wollen dafür sorgen dass
Berlin eine sichere und eine saubere
Stadt wird wo die Polizei eine moderne
Ausstattung bekommt und die
Unterstützung die sie braucht für ihre
schwere Arbeit wir wollen das Thema das
mietenproblem den Mieten Notstand den
ich immer angesprochen habe in den
letzten Wochen dass dieses Problem
ernsthaft gelöst wird wir wollen den
Mieterschutz auf neue Beine stellen wir
wollen dass der Mieterschutz
funktioniert in Berlin und wir wollen
den Wohnungsbau voranbringen wir wollen
das Angebot hochfahren
wir wollen dafür sorgen dass in dieser
Stadt eine mobilitätspolitik entsteht
die für alle funktioniert für
Fahrradfahrer für Fußgänger für Nutzer
des öffentlichen Personennahverkehrs
aber eben auch für das Auto wir werden
uns das Thema Klimaschutz annehmen wir
haben hier große Herausforderungen zu
bewältigen wir haben Ziele die wir
erreichen wollen im Bereich des
Klimaschutzes und hier wollen wir ein
ganz neuen Schub drauf bringen das
Berlin die Ziele erreicht und hier
werden wir auch einen neuen Schwerpunkt
als Koalition legen ich freue mich jetzt
auf die nächsten Wochen die nächsten
Beratungen mit der Berliner SPD noch mal
das waren sehr gute sehr offene
Gespräche wo auch neues Vertrauen
entstanden ist wo wir das gemeinsame
Ziel haben die Probleme dieser Stadt
jetzt anzugehen und sie wirklich zu
lösen und ich bin sehr optimistisch dass
wir das in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
auch gut hinbekommen
Herr Gabriel
hier aufgewühlt wie sehr zerstritten
auch bei der Frage ob man mit der CDU
koordinieren sollte möchten Sie dass das
auch die die Verhandlungen belasten
können und möglicherweise auch dann das
gemeinsame regieren dass das also ein
dauerhafter Konflikt verwenden könnte
also mit der sondierungskommission der
Berliner Sozialdemokraten hatten wir
wirklich sehr gute Gespräche wo wir uns
auf einem Fahrplan aber auch vor allen
Dingen auf inhaltliche Punkte
verständigt haben und ich habe vor allen
Dingen zur Kenntnis genommen dass die
Berliner SPD in geheimer Abstimmung mit
einem ganz klaren Votum für die Aufnahme
von Koalitionsverhandlungen bestimmt hat
ich glaube das ist eine sehr sehr gute
Basis wo beide Parteien CDU und SPD
jetzt in die Verhandlung auch gehen
können
ich habe es ja gesagt
wir haben viele Schnittmengen auch
festgestellt und auch ja wir haben
Brücken gebaut bei den Berliner Grünen
gemeinsam sowohl wir als auch die Grünen
über Gräben aber die Schnittmengen mit
den Sozialdemokraten sind größer und was
wir jetzt noch erreichen müssen in den
nächsten dreieinhalb Jahren bis zur
nächsten Wahl dass wir Punkte anpacken
und lösen dass wir schnell zu
Ergebnissen kommen denn eines das nehme
ich zumindestens sehr ernst nach den
gesamten Wahl nach Umfragen viele
Berlinerinnen und Berliner haben nicht
mehr das Vertrauen in die Politik und
das müssen wir hinbekommen das müssen
wir wieder herstellen und hier zu einer
verlässlichen Regierungsarbeit zu kommen
wo wir gemeinsam an einem Strang ziehen
um Berlin voranzubringen da glaube ich
können wir mit den Berliner
Sozialdemokraten jetzt eine Basis
herstellen und dann auch schnell ins
Handeln kommen
wann geht es los mit den Verhandlungen
gibt es schon so was für ein Preisplan
das Ziel ist dass wir die Arbeitsgruppen
am kommenden Montag
einsetzen hier wird der Landesvorstand
der Berliner SPD auch Tagen wir sind da
im Austausch und wir wollen kommende
Woche bereits mit der dachgruppe
zusammenkommen um die weiteren Schritte
zu besprechen also in der nächsten Woche
geht's mit den koalitionsverhandlung los
wissen sie es geht weder um Affären noch
im Lebensabschnitte sondern es geht um
eine stabile verlässliche Regierung für
Berlin und hier haben wir in den letzten
Wochen eine gute Grundlage gelegt jetzt
werden wir das Programm festlegen in den
nächsten Wochen und dann geht es mir
einzig und allein darum die Probleme und
die Herausforderungen die die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner Tag täglich
in ihrem täglichen Leben spüren
abzuarbeiten und zu verbessern und das
wollen wir dreieinhalb Jahre machen
gemeinsam CDU und SPD und ich freue mich
darauf
noch die Linken Jusos die ja auch
gestern eine Rolle gespielt haben die
haben jetzt noch mal zur Sprache
gebracht eine Sie als Administrator
einer Facebook-Gruppe die
rechtskonservativ mindestens ist wie ist
es dazu gekommen dass sie da
Administrator wurden und warum ab
welchem Punkt haben sich entschieden
dass sie doch bei dieser Gruppe die auch
der Homepage hatte sowas wie impfen
macht frei ab wann haben sie entschieden
da wegzugehen vor langer Zeit vor
anderthalb Jahren ist eine Gruppe die
ein CDU-Mitglied gegründet hat wo er
unterschiedliche Leute einlädt sie
müssen mal schauen wie viele da drin
sind ist ganz spannend und auch
SPD-Mitglieder mit SPD Abgeordnete mit
dabei grüne also viel viele viele
Menschen sind dabei
so ich war auch in dieser Gruppe ich bin
vor anderthalb Jahren ausgetreten weil
ich Kenntnis bekommen habe was dort
gepostet wird und deswegen bin ich da
ausgetreten Punkt Ende aus so mehr als
dazu gar nicht zu sagen von den Inhalten
die dort in dieser Gruppe gepostet
worden distanziere ich mich ausdrücklich
das war der Grund warum ich dort
ausgetreten bin und mehr ist dazu nicht
zu sagen zu den Users und den schrillen
Tönen der Jusos wissen sie das ist doch
das gute Recht ich war auch mal
Vorsitzender einer Jugendorganisation
und hatte damals auch eine Meinung und
ich kann mich noch sehr sehr gut
erinnern 1999 gab es einen Regierenden
Bürgermeister Eberhard diepken in Berlin
das gab einen eine Wahl der damals und
ich war angehender Landesvorsitzender
der Jungen Union und habe damals auch
immer an wir müssen doch jetzt alles
durchsetzen und wir als CDU und ich habe
heute über Diebin gesagt dass ich heute
deutlich mehr Verständnis für seine
Positionen im Jahr 1999 hatte als ich
vielleicht damals gehabt habe also von
daher ist das gute Recht von
Jugendorganisation und Parteien müssen
damit umgehen
nur wir haben noch 1 2 1 2 1 2 3
also nochmal das Thema Enteignung
dass da haben wir nicht zugestimmt ich
halte weiterhin Enteignung für den
falschen Weg das löst keine Probleme
aber nichtsdestotrotz haben wir ein
Volksentscheid den wir ernst nehmen und
wir werden jetzt schauen wie wir damit
umgehen das haben wir mit den
Sozialdemokraten besprochen und genau
diesen Weg wenn wir jetzt noch mal
vertiefen in den Koalitionsverhandlungen
und diesen Weg werden wir gehen
oder
wissen sie das ist doch so ein in einer
Koalition wird man nie hundert Prozent
durchsetzen das gilt für uns und das
gilt auch für die Sozialdemokraten und
wir haben uns jetzt auf einen
gemeinsamen Weg verständigt und dieser
gemeinsame Weg ist sofern ich dann
Regener Bürgermeister werde auch mein
Weg und da mache ich dann auch gar keine
Unterschiede ich bin nicht Regierender
Bürgermeister nur einer Partei und ich
will auch nicht Regierender
Bürgermeister nur einer Koalition sein
sondern ich möchte der Regierende
Bürgermeister der Berlinerinnen und
Berliner sein mit einer starken
Koalition die mich dabei unterstützt und
ich sage Ihnen auch in aller Klarheit
ich werde auch in den nächsten Jahren
darauf achten nicht nur mit der
Koalition eng zusammenzuarbeiten sondern
auch mit den demokratischen
Oppositionsparteien in Berliner
Abgeordnetenhaus weil wir haben große
Aufgaben vor uns wir wollen eine
Verwaltungsreform in Berlin hinbekommen
und für eine echte Verwaltungsreform
brauchen wir eine Verfassungsänderung
und da brauchen wir auch die
Oppositionsparteien und ich werde auch
mit der demokratischen Opposition hier
das Gespräch suchen und Zusammenarbeiten
das ist mein Anspruch und mein Ziel ich
will für Berlin arbeiten und dass diese
Stadt endlich besser funktioniert
drei Jahren zu schaffen das ist ein
Anspruch den wir haben das ist keine
einfache Aufgabe aber einfach kann jeder
und wer sich meine Vita anschaut weiß
auch dass ich nie den einfachen Weg
genommen habe immer den bisschen
komplizierteren und mein Anspruch ist es
ganz klar das ist auch der Anspruch von
CDU und SPD das haben wir klar
formuliert dass wir in den nächsten
dreieinhalb Jahren hart daran arbeiten
dass es tagtäglich ein Stück besser wird
dass wir nicht von heute auf morgen alle
Probleme lösen das wissen wir alle
gemeinsam aber die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner müssen spüren in den nächsten
dreieinhalb Jahren dass ich vieles zum
Besseren verändert hat das ist mein Ziel
gemeinsam mit CDU und SPD